so what did you think of never skip
dessert I was making fun of Fitness
people because my original audience was
Fitness people who obsessed about like
not eating cookies and I was like
off yeah I mean like eat dessert but do
it in a way that you can solve a
six-pack the whole time so that was why
I never skipped it was always like never
Skip Leg Day never skip Monday and I was
like no script like the Cavs thing is
because like I genuinely have started
training since a girl told me that she
thought that my calves weren't big so
it's been like 12 years 14 years that I
start every session with caps my calves
have grown a lot my calves were sticks
and I trained the out so like is it
part of my brand yeah because it's in
some ways like it's true